what do rihanna and the red hot chili
peppers have in common
a deep admiration for brandy norwood
she's been called your favorite singer's
favorite singer the artist known as the
vocal bible is both a grammy winner and
television star brandi has had many
highs in her career and was the it girl
in the 90s and early 2000s but even
still brandy's vocal talent and
innovation are not recognized enough
so we are going to talk about it
brandi was only 14 years old when she
recorded her first single i wanna be
down
the minimal arrangement combined with
her impressive vocal chops won over the
hearts of r b and pop listeners alike
[Music]
what do you think may brandi stand out
early in her career what do you think
made her pop
so i think there is this very polished
look that was super intentional in this
innocence um that made her very um
loving so that worked what's her tone
brandy it's only one time you know it
out of a thousand voices she's just
she's a quiet storm but brandi didn't
reach that level of success overnight
born in 1979 she spent most of her
childhood in carson california
brandy's father was a gospel singer and
a minister of music yes that's right
brandy got her musical foundation in the
church she even started singing in the
church choir at the age of two brandi's
life was changed after seeing whitney
houston on tv for the first time
she remembers telling her mom i want to
be as big as whitney houston by the time
she was 12 years old she was already
singing back up for the teen r b group
immature
and it took her only a year or two to
land her own record deal with atlantic
it's important to remember that the
musical landscape of the 1980s looked
nothing like we're used to today
labels struggled to find mainstream
success with young black women stars
there were a few artists who left their
mark like tracy spencer penny ford and
janet jackson but even they struggled to
break out of the r b charts and cross
over to pop between white artists
infusing pop with r b elements and black
artists getting closer to mainstream
than ever before
brandy had a real shot at becoming a
superstar and brandi did become a
superstar in 1997 she started cinderella
alongside her hero whitney houston she
got her own tv show moisha
sold barbie dolls and even cut a deal
with covergirl
so how did brandy grow into a
heavyweight and what makes her voice so
special it all starts with her greatest
influence whitney houston you can hear
the whitney influence in her debut album
with songs like baby
or brokenhearted
[Music]
i feel like she was able to use whitney
houston as kind of her launching pad
into being a lot more inventive and a
lot more thoughtful and okay where else
can i go musically in what ways do you
hear that whitney influence in her music
you know if you if you really go back
and you listen to a lot of her ballads
although that's whitney if you listen to
that and you put it side by side with i
believe in you and me
it's the same vocal style yeah and that
my favorite one is the one this one's
like
let me live just so i can sing for you
sounds like panty
yes
it sounds like if if whitney were still
making music something that she would be
doing
exactly collaborating with acclaimed
musicians like rodney jerkins and late
vocal producer lashawn daniels brandy
implemented a vocal style that felt
effortless to the listener
randy's vocal agility fast vibrato and
crystal clear runs soon became her
trademark rather than testing the limits
of her belting power and vocal range
brandy focuses on her mid-register with
great control
taking inspiration from jazz singers she
often utilizes the mixed voice approach
by mixing her chest voice and her head
voice she brings an airy and buttery
quality to her singing
[Music]
perhaps this is one of the reasons why
her voice still sounds as flexible as
ever today
even when she belts she does so with
care
she knows exactly how long to sustain a
note
and how soon to descend off of it
[Music]
that's fire that's why her use of
tensions and knowing how to like use an
approach note you know and then like a
suspension so in later years full moon
fomo she literally
while the corners just doing all the
things
[Music]
the woman is singing down
like many r b singers brandy is also a
fan of ad-libs she often adds to the
story of each song by inserting new
melodic layers to top off the main theme
[Music]
every element feels intentional and it
intensifies the emotional impact on the
listener grammy award-winning gospel
singer-songwriter erica campbell said it
best it's a perfect marriage of vocal
and lyric ready is piano brandi is a
string section oh wow her arrangements
are arrangements
there are pads with orchestrations or an
orchestration like it's you can strip
away
all instrumentation of a brandy song and
have a full song there's a reason why
many consider brandy's third album to be
her greatest body of work in full moon
it was time to showcase the depth of her
abilities brandi said she believed the
track what about us could change the
game
the offbeat futuristic song took
influence from hip hop and dance pop
[Music]
rodney jerkins had a field day on full
moon
and
if you listen to full moon if this is
the very first song on there called i
thought you were mine
you'll hear
the way that he used that same
production on feedback for janet jackson
four or five years later
[Music]
rodney jerkins literally found his sound
and my opinion on the brandy full moon
album
brandy is an out as a singer that
producers can find their sound in as she
was in the studio finishing up the
production of full moon brandi found out
that she was pregnant with her daughter
sarai
now the mother of a toddler in her 20s
brandi was ready to show the world what
adulthood looked like through her eyes
first she said goodbye to her long-time
collaborator rodney jerkins and brought
in timbaland to produce her fourth
studio album
aphrodisiac in this album brandy's voice
sounds more raw than ever before boldly
referencing coldplay and i try this
classic r b tune aligns brandy's ad-libs
with her building frustration and regret
in the face of infidelity
[Music]
[Applause]
with the release of aphrodisiac brandy's
vocal trinity was finally complete
between never say never
full moon and aphrodisiac she provided
the perfect guidebook for r b artists
for many years to come
given the plethora of female artists now
dominating the game it's easy to forget
how it all began solange once said
brandy is a goddess in r b to a lot of
people she is really the foundation for
a lot of this very innovative
progressive experimental r b
brandy influenced a lot of that there's
a reason why solange one of the most
experimental r b artists of today puts
brandy on a pedestal
nowadays it's common to hear singers use
their voices in unconventional ways but
back when brandy was on her way up that
approach was practically unheard of okay
so i i have a question
that i'm nervous to ask you but can you
teach me some of brandi's vocal
techniques oh my gosh yes what song are
we gonna do
i don't know well um okay so my favorite
song one of my favorite songs is when
you touch me really
miss you baby
okay
freely
miss you baby
so you want to be really specific about
where you put vibrato when it comes to
singing gravity okay it's gonna be a
challenge for me
to not sing with vibrato really
miss you baby
oh i caught myself
vibrato isn't a bad thing it's just not
true to brandy's aesthetic it's like
it's so specific in our world we call it
chiaroscuro the blend of light and dark
like it's just different for her it's
really unique it doesn't really go by
the standard like you can tell she took
the standard and kind of modified it for
her signature sound today brandi is
evidently still working on expanding her
range showcasing a few previously
unheard falsetto tones on songs like i
am more
[Music]
r b is a huge part of mainstream pop
music today in part thanks to brandy
propelling the genre forward during a
time where black female artists were all
but missing from the charts her tv shows
movies and endorsement deals helped her
reach role model status but it was her
musical excellence that cemented her
legacy thanks for tuning in to our
brandy episode
a friend of mine and the creator of
soundfield has started a new project
inspired by sound field that goes beyond
music i'll let joseph tell you about it
working on sound field inspired me to
create a new pbs documentary series
called subculture which explores how
lesser-known communities have influenced
the mainstream culture around us i've
met with a blonde gamer who plays mortal
kombat professionally i've met cowboys
and cowgirls from the gay rodeo and i've
also explored how anime became a 25
billion dollar industry check it out on
the pbs voices link in our description
and let them know that soundfield sent
you here are your submissions from our
last video when we asked you what your
favorite pop punk song is ever fallen in
love by the buzzcocks is perfect and i
could listen to it every day until i die
as always thanks for watching
we want to hear what your favorite
brandy vocal moment is
if you'd like you can submit a video of
yourself telling us your favorite songs
at the link in the description